мене звати Максим драбок А це мій колега
Романа Гончаренко і ми перебуваємо тут
на полях Мюнхенської конференції з
безпеки а саме в кулуарах Ви чуєте Зараз
іде одна з панелей і там виступає
міністр оборони
Німеччини якраз іде дискусія про
озброєння і так далі ми Закликаємо вас
ставити запитання я принагідно разом з
Романом ми будемо на них відповідати
Отже зараз підійб'ємо проміжні пісню
конференції про що домовилися в Мюнхені
І власне коли закінчиться війна це
запитання цікавить усіх від політиків до
пересічних громадян і цікаво сказати що
саме президент Зеленський фактично задав
тон цим строкам так він сказав що ми
можемо тобто Україна закінчити війну
протягом року
або навіть і швидше і так щоб зустрітися
на наступній мюнхенській конференції
тобто у лютому наступного року вже тут і
від знайти перемогу і так далі Отже нам
твою думку романи - це реалістично чи ні
важко сказати це питання справді тут
луналов під час різних дискусій І от
буквально кілька хвилин тому ще міністра
яка закордонних справ Німеччини аналіна
бервок сказала відверто що ми не можемо
сказати українцям коли закінчиться ця
війна ніхто цього не знає але ми можемо
робити те що Ми продовжуємо робити те що
ми обіцяли робити підтримувати України
стільки скільки це знадобиться
відповідно постачати і зброю і я думаю
що тут нам мюнхенській конференції а
підтримка України була просто величезна
а не пам'ятаю ніколи такої великої
делегацією з українського боку такою
уваги до України як була зараз тобто
президент Зеленський відкрив конференцію
в перший день виступив ще до канцлера
Шульца і президента фракції Франції
еммануе ль макрона відповідно люди
аплодували стоячи йому як і на інших
таких заходах тобто
всюди українські прапори і це
відчувається ця атмосфера постійно чути
українську мову в коридорах багато дуже
представників українських е-е
жодної теж іде така своєрідна демо
ситуація багато людей в Україні жовтого
блакитних кольорах і вони виступають за
те що почули і швидше надавали більше
підтримки повинні бути так щоб ми були
трошечки
після
чи ти вважаєш що ця конференція
допомогла України можливо Україні
переконати ті країни які ще вагалися і
можливо думали чи постачати наприклад
там
леопард-2 німецькі про які дуже багато
дискусій точилося сама Німеччина була в
центрі критики ще кілька тижнів тому це
важко собі уявити як швидко змінився
світ правда
тобто Німеччина критикували що вона А
зволікає І от зараз Коли ми з тобою
Виявляється що німеччинах країн хто
пообіцяв і зараз готується тобто вже йде
навчання українських військових на цих
німецьких танках самі танки Очевидно в
березні потраплять в Україну так само як
і БМП тобто бойові машини Мардер які теж
А їх тільки десятків передає Німеччина і
Україна обновно вже більше року Просила
передати їх і от нарешті це настане так
от я кажу який парадокс правда Німеччина
була об'єктом критики і тепер Німеччина
критикує інших за те що ті зволікають а
і як Мені пояснили деякі тут Люди з
якими ми спілкувалися мовляв виявилося
що у деяких країн не так багато танків
які можна віддати е-е і вони пояснюють
це те що там якісь проблеми з технічним
станом а тим не менше от така ситуація
як твоє враження так Ну Мої враження
особисті те що захід Нарешті оговтувався
ми з роману багато років висвітлювали
мілківську конференцію завжди чули
запевнення от
виступало саме в цей день Меркель
минулого року і віце-президент пенс і
теж були такі меседжі ключові що е
берегти перемогти Ми можемо тільки разом
коли буде єдність а програти кожен
поодинці програє якщо не подає Європу не
було про це було шість років Це все було
Це було дійсно каденції коли він був і
Трамп вони звісно не в минулому рік так
так що нагадував на кілька річної
давнини от Тому зараз я вважаю що захід
як ніколи єдиний він як ніколи
згуртований Але знову ж таки багато
чуття що це саме на словах тобто вони
обмежуються прапорами обмежуються
якимось кольорами жовто-блакитними
замість реальних якихось фізичних речей
на кшталт не зброї на кшталт танків
літаків амуніції більш артилерії з
іншого боку це нам хотілося б отримати
якомога швидше і якомога більше але
треба розуміти їх Вони теж зброя
постачає постачається тобто вони роблять
це можливо звісно але й що це теж вони
не можуть взяти і віддати все що в них є
чи і так далі багато є виникло проблем з
цією війною що на папері як у
армії там Росії чи де в них були якісь
моменти а якесь озброєння по факту воно
або лижному стані би ще щось тобто вся
ця ситуація вся ця війна змусила захід
замислитися що вони всі ці роки вони
роззброювалися вони робили
димілітаризацію в своїй території а в
підсумку виявилося не готовими тобто я
думаю що це зміна всіх такі перехід на
інше ставлення до ризиків до безпеки і
до міжнародних політиків як такої яка
зараз переживає свої тектонічні суттєві
зміни щодо зброї Я думаю тут варто
згадати що Мюнхенська конференція це
завжди
переговори десь на полях тобто в окремих
кабінетах без преси куди ми не маємо
доступу і там ухвалюються теж якісь
важли рішення і звичайно такий
проговорилися і зараз вони велися з
представниками України і звичайно
головна тема була це постачання зброї Ми
говорили з деякими українськими
представниками Про це вони кажуть так
справді такі переговори були ми чули що
були переговори можливостей і виробляє
також ці гаубиці які Україна вже
використовує німецькі пацих так от
Наскільки я розумію Ми можливо
дізнаємось через деякий час проте чи є
якісь конкретні домовленості тут у
Мюнхені в будь-якому разі ці питання
обговорювалися і я б ще зазначив що от є
такий теж важливий момент так це деталі
і От ця деталь дуже багатьох умовах
західних політиків лунало вже як факт що
Україна стане членом європейської родини
тобто Чемпіонату і е про НАТО там ще не
так категорично говорять очікуючи що
війна має закінчитися але проє говорять
конкретно тому що по-перше
має вже цей статус країни кандидата на
вступ які вони разом Молдовою кілька
місяців тому влітку у 22-го року і це
звичайно це ж така історична подія от
багато хто згадував це в речах і це
згадувалося як вже нормально ми вже
рухаємося далі І от просто я ще зовсім
не звик до такого темпу тому що ми майже
20 років
обговорювали бажання України нарешті
наблизитися до Європейського Союзу і от
так сталося Що Україна мала стати
жертвою Росії щоб це нарешті відбулося і
цей поїзд почав порухатися і от він
рухався ми тут в Мюнхені це дуже сильно
відчуваємо І от теж цікавий момент а
аналіна Деревок міністра яка закордонних
справ Німеччини виступаючи тут сказали
коли її спитали коли йшлося про гарантії
для України гарантії безпеки Вона
сказала що в принципі вже найбільша
гарантія вже є це обіця нка взята
України в Європейські Союз Вона сказала
що у нас теж є е-е ця стаття про
колективну безпеку в Європейському Союзі
тобто важко собі уявити що Україна стане
членом є через кілька років а вона стане
я в цьому переконаний і там умовно
кажучи напад Росії Росії
той момент і союзники не відреагують в
Європейському суді
на той момент ну цікава теж власне
почалася дискусія сьогодні чи боїться
захід опаду Росії Українська влада
використовував багато її представників
принаймні Виходить з того щоб
забезпечити безпеку України треба щоб не
було Росії в нинішньому вигляду тобто
човна розпалася на декілька частин захід
до цієї тези як на мене ще не готовий
відповідно
тому що не буде контролю за ядерною
зброєю за іншою зброєю не буде єдиного
центру прийняття рішень з ким вести
переговори з рештою і так далі тобто
Якщо раніше не були готові західні
країни до того щоб постачити танки якусь
там іншу летальну зброю зараз
обговорення літаків то зараз до цього не
готові і новообраний президент Чехії
власне про це сказав що він не хотів би
щоб цього не було і одразу почалася
реакція перш за все з українського боку
що треба вірити в Україну треба
перемогти і так далі на твою думку все ж
таки оцей розпад Росії його боїться чому
чому власне тому що було б ну
що зрештою Росія була би в інших
кордонах Це був би зовсім інша Росія і
не така небезпечна для сусідів це дуже
небезпечно для заходу ця дискусія
оскільки це дає Росії момент е-е що
відмовляв дивіться вони е-е є загрозою
для нас тобто Росія і зараз про це
говорить але якщо не застосування якщо
західні країни почнуть говорити про те
що вони хочуть розпаду всі Звичайно це
дасть зброю для Російської пропаганди
ніхто цього не хоче а головна причина
про це те про що ти питаєш Це в тому що
ядерна держава ніхто не знає як я
державно-держав себе поведе захід е бо
бобоювався розпаду Радянського Союзу
саме з цієї причини тоді пощастило з
точки зору заходу як буде зараз ніхто не
знає бо це інша країна Росію дуже важко
порівнювати з радянським союзом бо вона
поводиться набагато більше агресивно і
непередбачувано ніж радянський сою
за великим рахунком таких дискусій про
майбутнє Росії тут майже нема одна так
годині і це теж такий певний символізм
раніше про Росію і стосунки говорили в
головний день конференції в суботу в
першій половині дня російський Міністр
закордонних справ Сергій Лавров виступав
всі його слухали завжди був повний зал
до Росії дослухалися тобто ці всі
розповіді які ми чуємо з Росії про те що
її ніхто не слухав Принаймні про Мюнхен
цього не можна сказати на мюнхенській
конференції завжди до Росії дуже поважно
ставилися вона була один із членів
наглядової ради а Мюнхенської
конференції тобто
голова Мюнхенської конференції говорив
що Сергія Лавров його друг ну це було ще
до кримських подій але і пізніше в них
були досить приязні стосунки
зміни то і сама Мюнхенська конференція
змінилася тому що у неї тепер новий
голова це кристоф-польським колишній
радник канцлера Меркель колишній
представник Німеччини в ООН він був на
Мінських переговорах він був на всіх
зустрічах ключових з Росією Де
меркельтаж також брала участь він
супроводжував її і в Київ і в Москву він
чудово знає що відбувається
самі він сказав він напередодні
прес-конференції Мюнхені сказав що треба
Росії щоб повернулися в цей клуб
цивілізований країн Треба спершу зробити
депонетизацію тобто ініціацію так це
дуже радикальна заява фраза тобто він
тоді не на цих полях почути таке ще
навіть Минулого року я собі не уявляв я
теж здивований був Але тим не менше він
і підтримує надання Україні літаків що
не робить наприклад офіційний Берлін Він
підтримує повернення Криму тобто він
порівнюючи з його попередником
німецьким дипломатом він набагато більш
радикально в своїх позиціях хоча це
радикалізм він спричинений за великим
рахунком поведінкою Росії тобто саме
війна стала таким водорозділом для нього
і відчувалося коли він відкривав
конференцію Це був такий теж емоційний
момент коли він підводив президента
України і там був виступ одного піаніста
і показували кадри зруйнованих
українських міст так от завершуючи своє
вступне слово польське мало не заплакав
тобто відчувалося що його ця війна
торкнулася дуже сильно особисто і це ми
чули потім сьогодні в другий день
конференції коли виступала
віце-президентка Сполучених Штатів кем
ларис Тобто вона говорила дуже багато
пробучу про ці злочини які бачив світ
початку війни коли росіяни відійшли з
півночі України і всі побачили так Так і
вона говорила що ці злочини не повинні
залишитися без наслідків
потрібний трибунал і ці люди які вчинили
ці злочини які віддавали надавали накази
Вони мають бути покарані і вона дуже
багато згадувала про згвалтованих дітей
там про деякі кори тут на конференції
говорили їх Очевидно це сильно зачепило
знаєш коли оця історія про те що дітей
вивозять в Росію АА і ця ці новини от
нещодавно був звіт а-а в Сполучених
Штатах саме про це про себе писало
багато світу речень і взагалі Європі ця
тема чіпляє
Тому це в принципі теж частина цієї
Мюнхенської конференції оці згадки що
зараз і що треба робити всі усвідомлюють
що треба підтримувати України надалі але
от цікавий момент а я не знаю як і в
тебе досвід я спілкувався з кількома
людьми так куарно без мікрофона і от в
них таке враження що
їхній прогноз війна триватиме швидше за
все ще кілька років і ми тільки замах
зараз на самому початку і на заході теж
немає поки що 100% єдності як бути далі
які які види озброєння
зі зброєю це дає можливість Путіну До
речі от ми задалеко не локаріс Тобто
вона сказала Прямим текстом що зараз
вигідно Путіну оця передишка він думає
що час ми його боці потім думають що
тобто щоб він встигне що захід втомиться
населення країн втомиться будуть вибори
в багатьох країнах про це багато згав в
Європі і так далі і відповідно що е-е
тоді і зменшився підтримка України але
вона чітко йде декілька разів повторила
короткими емоційними реченнями що цього
не відбудеться І що захід е буде до
останнього стійкість такий треба і
робити все що потрібно для України Тобто
вона дала зрозуміти що час не на боці
Путіна Я думаю що це меседж е-е почули в
Кремлі принаймні і ясно дуже сподіваюся
можливо це ви ж тим ким тобто очі
видавати бажаний за дійсне але я все ж
таки сподіваюся що наступною Мюнхенської
конференції ми будемо вже
обговорювати інше а саме відновлення і
відбудову України Отже Дякую нашій
шановні е-е глядачі це були Максим
Драбов і Роман Гончаренко із кулуарів
Мюнхенської конференції з безпеки ми
підбили попередні підсумки і конференції
ще триває отже не Стежте за нашими
новинами на усіх ресурсах до